[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne gellineck guten Abend
zwei Schritte vor und einen zurück so
könnte man das Ergebnis des brüsselers
EU-Gipfel zusammenfassen gestern Abend
herrschte noch riesen Freude darüber
dass es gelungen ist der Ukraine die
Aufnahme von Beitrittsverhandlungen
anzubieten wenn auch mit dem
Schönheitsfehler dass der der dagegen
war halt nicht mitstimmte heute kam das
dicke Ende der Ungar Orban blockiert die
Aufstockung des EU-Haushalts und damit
auch Milliardenhilfen für die Ukraine
beim Geld funktionierte der 26 Z1 Trick
nicht gun Krüger aus
Brüssel in Brüssel haftet Olaf Scholz
der Ruf an erführre nicht genug heute
morgen ist das
anders erhebt euch ruft einer im Scherz
aber auch mit Anerkennung der Kanzler
setzte den Beginn von beitritt
Handlungen für die Ukraine durch mit
einem Trick der
verblüfft ich werde das einmal in meinen
Memoiren aufschreiben irgendwann nicht
heute es ist schon interessant wie der
Hase
läuft und zwar so der Platz von Ungarn
das bislang blockierte blieb leer Vikor
Orban ging auf des kanzlersvorschlag
Kaffee trinken so war kein nein auch ein
ja das ist jetzts was mal machen sollte
wir sollten schon meistens dazu kommen
dass wir miteinander entscheiden und uns
eben zusammenbringen ich finde die Welt
besteht daraus dass man Konsense und
Kompromisse formuliert die sind nicht so
dass sie vom Himmel fallen ein
Kompromiss fehlt um 3 Uhr morgens Orban
sagt weiter Nein zur Finanzhilfe der EU
für den Haushalt der Ukraine er will
selbstgeld das die EU sperrt wegen
Mängeln in Ungarns Justizsystem
Milliarden gegen Milliarden Orban presst
die EU und versteckt es kaum im
staatlichen
Fernsehen dies ist eine großartige
Gelegenheit deutlich zu machen dass wir
bekommen was uns rechtmäßig zusteht
nicht die Hälfte oder ein Viertel
sondern alles wir wollen eine faire
Behandlung und jetzt haben wir eine gute
Chance sie zu
bekommen das System Orban die EU muss
darauf reagieren einer mnt statt zu
tricken
ich habe nicht gejubelt ich erwarte von
Victor Orban in den nächsten Monaten
dass er sich als Europäer verhält und
dass er den politischen Fortschritt
nicht als Geisel
nimmt ein Fortschritt ohne Orban also
Ukraine Hilfe außerhalb des EU-Haushalts
hätte seinen
Preis wenn wir andere Finanzierungswege
gehen dann brauchen wir die Parlamente
und es wird viel komplizierter wir sind
Demokratie die brauchen Zeit und die
Ukraine hat keine
Zeit darum wird auch der deutsche
Kanzler noch im Januar wieder in Brüssel
sein er braucht dann echte Kompromisse
und nicht nur
kaffeetricks haushaltsnöte auch zu Hause
in Berlin bevor die Regierungskoalition
nun den Plan für den Sparhaushalt 2024
in die parlamentarische Beratung gibt
musste sie heute erst mal den et fürs
laufende Jahr reparieren der Bundestag
beschloss also für dieses Jahr erneut
das Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse und den
Nachtragshaushalt ampelvorsatz fürs neue
Jahr ist aber die Schuldengrenze wieder
einzuhalten unterdessen veröffentlichte
die Bundesbank am Morgen ihre
Wachstumsprognose die schlechte
Nachricht die Wirtschaft kommt nicht in
Gang die gute die Inflation sinkt und
sofort kommt der Ruf nach der
Zinssenkung Isabelle della Weeger
berichtet
Party Stimmung an der Börse der DAX im
Rekordflug jetzt schon feiern Sie dass
die EZB den Leitzins bald senken könnte
und das Geld dann wieder billig würde
diese Freude sei verfrüht so Experten
die Notenbank hat ja während der
zurückliegenden hochinflationsphase auch
deutlich an Vertrauen auch an Reputation
eingebüst das ist aber das wichtigste
Kapital einer Notenbank und deshalb
möchte sie sich jetzt keinen
Schlingerkurs erlauben und H dann eben
die Zinsschraube noch etwas ruhig die
EZB hat die Inflation in den Griff
bekommen doch es gibt Hörden auf dem Weg
zu sinkenden Preisen die erste die
Bundesregierung will den CO2 Ausstoß
teurer
machen also als Hausbesitzer oder
Wohnungsbewohner der eine Heizung hat
die mit fossilen
Energieträgern betrieben wird ein Auto
das mit entsprechend fossilen
Energieträgern fährt die Preise werden
ansteigenwe Hürde für Preissenkungen die
internationalen Konflikte spitzen sich
zu wir wollen unabhängiger von China
werden wir sehen die geopolitischen
Spannungen und das bedeutet aber dass
wir uns auch andere Lieferanten suchen
müssen das ist mit Kosten verbunden das
wird die Preise auch nach oben treiben
ein Inflationstreiber bleibt der
Fachkräftemangel weil es weniger
Fachkräfte gibt können diese höhere
Löhne durchsetzen also die höheren Löhne
greifen natürlich überall dort wo die
Dienstleistungen direkt im hier daran
hängen ob das im hotelen
gaststätdtengewerbe ist und in anderen
Bereichen die nicht staatlich geregelt
sind dort merken wir jetzt schon dass
die Preise deutlich angestiegen sind und
das ist das was ich auch weiter
verstätigen wird und das kann auch das
eh schon schwache Wirtschaftswachstum
Bremsen warum also die Party an der
Börse also die Party an der Börse
irritiert mich in der Tat man kann zwar
die Geschichte erzählen dass die
zinsgipfel erreicht sind aber die
gesamtwirtschaftliche Lage die ja
letztlich die Gewinn Wartungen
unterlegen muss sieht bei weitem nicht
so aus als dass wir hier hosian am
Aktienmarkt rufen könnten die Wirtschaft
in Schwung zu bringen aber auch
gleichzeitig die Inflation zu dämpfen
das bleibt eine
Herausforderung die Weltwirtschaft
sprintet nicht das hat der
Internationale Währungsfond im Herbst
festgestellt und Deutschland humpele
unter den G7 Ländern am stärksten die
Bundesbank kam heute ebenfalls mit einer
eher vorsichtigen Prognose für die
wicklung der nächsten Jahre bei uns im
Studio ist jetzt der oberste Banker
Bundesbankpräsident Joachim Nagel guten
Abend guten Abend sie haben heute ihre
Prognose in ihrer Prognose das erwartete
Wachstum nach unten korrigiert auf 0,4%
warum also zunächst mal haben wir das
erwartete Wachstum für dieses Jahr
leicht nach oben korrigiert nur nur -
0,1 aber in der Tat für das nächste Jahr
ein wenig dann korrigiert die Wirtschaft
nimmt nächstes Jahr nur gemäßigt Anlauf
auf dann für das Jahr 2024 auf dann 0,4%
das ist unsere Schätzung der
deutschlandprognose der Bundesbank was
sind denn die Gründe dafür dass es so
schwach anläuft also sicherlich sind die
Gründe dafür dass die
Auslandsnachfrage weiterhin relativ
schwach ist dass auch der private Konsum
in diesem Jahr noch relativ schwach war
nächstes Jahr sehen wir dann dass die
Nettoeinkommen wieder deutlicher steigen
und das führt dann dazu dass das
Wirtschaftswachstum dann wieder nach
oben zeigt aber in der Tat äh die
Wachstumsraten sind relativ schwach
nächstes Jahr sehen Sie die Inflation
allerdings nur noch bei
2,7% das ist ja schon ziemlich nah an
ihrem Ziel von 2% können die Zinsen also
dann wieder runter das ist sicherlich
die gute Nachricht der
deutschlandprognose der Bundesbank dass
die Inflation im nächsten Jahr mehr als
halbiert wird mit nach unserer Schätzung
2,7% das zeigt klar dass die
Zinserhöhung der Europäischen
Zentralbank ihre Wirkung zeigen wir
hatten ja ins insgesamt zehn Mal die
Zinsen erhöht und das sieht man jetzt
auch in in den Inflationsraten das sind
gute Nachrichten aber sie gehen jetzt
wieder runter mit den Zinsen habe ich
Sie richtig verstanden da haben sie mich
nicht richtig verstanden ich habe dazu
nichts gesagt was ich sehe ist
sicherlich so dass wir mit einer hohen
Wahrscheinlichkeit das zinsplateau
erreicht haben nach den zehn
Zinserhöhungen und dann werden wir
datenabhängig entscheiden wie es im
Jahresverlauf weitergeht aber es ist aus
meiner Sicht noch viel zu früh darüber
nachzudenken wann denn möglicherweise
Zinssenkung kommen könnten weil die
Inflation immer noch zu hoch ist unser
Ziel ist 2% nicht
2,7% und da haben wir noch eine
Wegstrecke zu gehen jetzt hat die
Bundesregierung in ihrem neuen
Haushaltsvorschlag muss man ja sagen ähm
hat vor die CO2 Abgabe zu erhöhen das
heißt das wird die Inflation auch noch
mal treiben heißt das dass die
Bundesbank und die Bundesregierung
gegeneinander arbeiten also ganz
bestimmt nicht zunächst mal ist es gut
dass man jetzt für 24 ein Haushalt
aufgestellt hat ich gehe davon aus dass
man sich auch im Bundestag dann
zusammenft et für diesen Haushalt es
gibt auch Sicherheit
Planungssicherheit und alles was wir
sehen in den Beschlüssen für den
Haushalt 24 sieht steigt danach aus dass
wir hier keine negativen Effekte haben
etwa dass die Inflationsrate nach oben
angeschoben wird und wir sehen auch
keine negativen Impulse auf den
wirtschaftlichen Ausblick insofern ist
der Haushalt 24 relativ ausbalanciert
also das macht nichts dass die
Bundesregierung die CO2 Abgabe erhöht
ich denke das ist eine politische
Entscheidung die CO2 Abgabe zu erh das
hängt natürlich ganz stark damit
zusammen wenn es um den
Transformationsprozess geht der
deutschen Wirtschaft alles was wir als
Bundesbank sehen ist es natürlich so
dass so ein Transformationsprozess am
Anfang mit leichten preiseffekten
einhergeht aber uns in der Geldpolitik
an der Stelle keine großen Sorgen
bereiten aber in der Tat der
Transformationsprozess wenn er dann
länger aufgeschoben wird könnte
möglicherweise mit höheren preiseffekten
in der Zukunft kommen deswegen aus
Notenbank Sicht ist die CO2 Abgabe und
die Erhöhung der Steuer durchaus
nachvollziehbar mhm also sie sagen die
Inflation bleibt noch eine Weile was
sagen Sie jetzt dem Häuslebauer der sein
Hausbauen will oder der Frau die ein
Kredit aufnehmen will um ein E-Auto zu
kaufen also der Häuselbauer ist
natürlich jetzt zuletzt durch schwierige
Zeiten gegang die Zinsen sind gestiegen
aber es gab ja auch gute Gründe warum
die Zinsen steigen mussten weil die
Inflation viel zu hoch war wir hatten
natürlich davor auch eine Dekade
überzinsen die sicherlich vielleicht
auch nicht typisch waren die
möglicherweise zu niedrig waren aber
zuletzt sind die Zinsen für die
Häuslebauer wieder gesunken und das
wichtigste für eine Wirtschaft ist dass
man in der Zukunft mit stabilen
niedrigen Inflationsraten wiederrechnen
kann und das ist eigentlich die
wichtigste Nachricht das gibt
Planungssicherheit für alle
wirtschaftliche Akteure auch für den
Häuslebauer und derjenige der sich eben
Gedanken macht möglicherweise über
Investitionen was ist also ihre
Botschaft an die deutschen dass wir
erstmal mit einer dauerhaft relativ
hohen Inflation rechnen müssen und einer
humpelnden Wirtschaft also die
Wirtschaft ist sicherlich da ist Luft
nach oben die Inflation ganz im
Gegenteil da ist der Ausblick wie gesagt
relativ gut besser geworden deutlich
besser geworden ich sehe die
Inflationsrate möglicherweise im Jahr
2025 dann tatsächlich bei dem Zielwert
von 2 % das das ist die gute Botschaft
aber für die deutsche Wirtschaft da
gibt's sicherlich das eine oder andere
strukturelle Thema was man angehen
sollte welches noch schn ja sicherlich
Demografie Digitalisierung der ganze
Prozess der dekarbonisierung da gibt's
einige Baustellen und da müssen wir
jetzt die Ärmel hochkremmeln und müssen
an das Thema rangehen und dann ist mir
auch nicht bange um die deutsche
Wirtschaft sagt Joachim Nagel
Bundesbankpräsident herzlichen Dank für
den Besuch bei uns im Studio ich danke
ih fürs
Gespräch das Gespräch haben wir vor
einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet der Nachtragshaushalt für
dieses Jahr hat auch den Bundesrat
passiert es stand aber noch mehr auf der
Agenda die Nachrichten mit gundol Go
einer der 24 Schlüsse die Einstufung von
Georgien und Moldau die künftig als
sichere Herkunftsstaaten gelten der
Bundesrat stimmte zu somit können
Asylanträge aus diesen Ländern schneller
bearbeitet und Rückführungen zügiger
umgesetzt werden 15% aller abgelehnten
Asylanträge stammen von Menschen aus
Georgien und Moldau die Bundesregierung
will der Ukraine Hilfsgüter im Wert von
über 6 Millionen Euro für diesen Winter
liefern 500 Stromgeneratoren und zwei
Wasseraufbereitungsanlagen sollen in
frontnahe Gebiete gebracht werden in den
letzten 24 Stunden wurde allein die
Region Cherson über 100 mal von der
russischen Armee beschossen Wohngebiete
wurden getroffen Zivilisten verletzt
Präsident selenski erwies auf dem
Militärfriedhof von Lemberg getöteten
Soldaten die letzte
Ehre seit dem 6 dezember gibt es kein
Lebenszeichen von Alexei navalni heute
wurde sein Anwalt per Gericht informiert
dass der gesundheitlich angeschlagene
kremmelkritiker aus seinem Gefängnis nah
Moskau an einen unbekannten Ort gebracht
worden sei im Sommer war der
Oppositionspolitiker wegen Extremismus
zu 19 Jahren Haft verurteilt worden die
USA die EU und die Bundesregierung sind
besorgt wegen seines
Verschwindens mit dem Ende der UN
Friedensmission minusma im
westafrikanischen Mali hat auch die
Bundeswehr das Land endgültig verlassen
die letzten
142 Soldaten wurden im niedersächsischen
wunsdorf von Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius für ihre Leistungen gewürdigt
bei dem 10 Jahre langen Einsatz waren
drei deutsche Soldaten getötet worden
Malis Zukunft ist ungewiss 2020 hatte
das Militär geputscht dann das sofortige
Ende der UN-Mission verlangt und sich
Russland an
genähert bundesaußenministerin bbock hat
Israel und die libanesischen hisbolla
Milizen dazu aufgerufen einen
Flächenbrand innerost zu verhindern beim
Besuch des libanesischen Außenministers
buabib mahnte sie zu äußerster
militärischer Zurückhaltung und
Deeskalation von allen Seiten zuvor
hatte die Außenministerin auch auf dem
Gemeindetag des Zentralrats der Juden
erneut gefordert dass die ham die Waffen
niederlege es gehe um die Sicherheit
Israels und der
Palästinenser die Kritik am israelischen
Vorgehen im Konflikt mit Hamas und
Palästinensern wird lauter Australien
Kanada und 12 EU-Staaten Deutschland war
nicht darunter forderten Israel auf die
Gewalt durch jüdische Siedler im
Westjordanland zu beenden der
amerikanische Präsident Joe Biden mahnte
die israelische Armee sich beim Vorgehen
im gaz darauf zu konzentrieren wie Leben
von Zivilisten gerettet werden könnten
die Lage in Gaza wird immer
verzweifelter Susanna Santina
berichtet der israelische Luftangriff
gestern in Raffa im Süden Gazas hat
viele Tote gefordert noch heute
versuchen Anwohner Überlebende zu finden
doch viele können nur noch tot geborgen
werden auch dieses
Kind es sind alles Zivilisten
unschuldige Kinder wir suchen seit
gestern Nachmittag
htausende waren in den Süden des
Gazastreifens geflohen und kämpfen hier
ums tägliche Überleben es fehlt an
allem bei Gott unsere Lage ist wirklich
tragisch besonders jetzt im
Winter warum lässt uns Netanyahu
bombardieren wenn sie Kämpfer töten
wollen okay aber warum wir was ist
unsere
Schuld wie in unweit von Raffa gehen die
israelische Bodenoffensive und
Luftangriffe unveränderter Härte weiter
hier kommt es heute zu einem tragischen
Zwischenfall bei dem drei Geiseln von
israelischen Soldaten getötet
werden die IDF hat versehentlich die
Geiseln verwechselt und sie als
Bedrohung
gesehen wir bedauern diese Tragödie sehr
unser aufrichtiges Beileid gilt den
Familien der Getöteten unterdessen
bemüht sich der amerikanische
Sicherheitsberater Sullivan um
Vermittlung traf sich mit Palästinenser
Präsident Abbas in ramala und
wiederholte worum er zuvor den Israel
premier netanahu gebeten hatte statt der
breiten Bodenoffensive gezielte
militärische
Operationen unser gemeinsames Ziel ist
sicherzustellen dass die Hamas nie
wieder zu einer Bedrohung für Israel
wird während wir die Gefahr für
Zivilisten verringern und mehr
humanitäre Hilfe in Gaza ermöglichen
wollen Trauer heute um einen dort
gefallenen Offizier solche Beerdigungen
sind zum Alltag in Israel geworden rund
450 israelische Soldaten wurden bislang
getötet
zuletzt wurden die Leichen dieser zwei
19-Jährigen israelischen Soldaten und
eines 28-Jährigen Franzosen geborgen er
war beim Nova Musikfestival am 7 Oktober
entführt
worden immer noch befinden sich 132
Geiseln in den Händen der Terroristen in
Tel Aviv kommen jeden Abend Angehörige
zusammen diese Menschen sollen nicht
vergessen
werden die Entführten sind schon seit 70
Tagen dort seit 70 Tagen man holt dort
nur leicht
wir müssen alle zusammenhalten aufstehen
und unser Land
verteidigen die Menschen hier spüren
fast täglich dass ihr Land im Krieg ist
raketenalarm heute Nachmittag in
Jerusalem das Abwehrsystem irondome kann
die Rakete
Abfangen der Krieg im Gazastreifen geht
also weiter gleichzeitig wird auch
Israel wir haben es gerade gesehen immer
noch beschossen von der Hamas aber auch
aus aus dem Norden von der Hisbollah im
Libanon in den letzten Wochen hat sich
noch eine weitere Gruppe in den Konflikt
eingemischt die Husi Milizen aus dem
Jemen sie zählen sich zu der vom Iran
unterstützten Achse des Widerstands
gegen den Westen und besonders gegen
Israel und bedrohen neuerdings die
internationale Schiffahrt mit Drohnen
und Raketen Nils Muni
berichtet ein US- Kriegsschiff im
Einsatz vor wenigen Tagen Abwehrraketen
der USS carne sollen Geschosse und
Drohnen aus der Luft abfangen bevor sie
ihr Ziel erreichen Containerschiffe auf
der Durchfahrt im Roten Meer dort sind
momentan verschiedene Kriegsschiffe als
Teil einer multinationalen marinetruppe
vor Ort um handelsfrachter zu schützen
die Gefahrenzone liegt im Süden des
Roten Meeres an der jemenitischen Küste
wo die von Iran unterstützten hui
Rebellen einen Teil Jemens beherrschen
seit Wochen beschießen die wie sie sagen
alle Schiffe die israelische Häfen
ansteuern in Solidarität mit palästin n
in Gaza innenpolitisch hat es einige
Vorteile sie können gegen ihre
Kontrahenden
Punkten und die Bewegung innerhalb des
Jemens Stärken außenpolitisch bringt es
einen enormen Prestige Gewinn in der
arabisch arabisch islamischen Welt
außerdem kann man somit wunderbar die
normalisierungsbestrebungen einige
arabischen Staaten mit Israel
torpedieren Angriffe gegen Unterstützer
Israels so wird etwa heute unter anderem
ein Frachtschiff des deutschen
Transportunternehmens par Leut getroffen
die Bundesregierung verurteilt alle
Angriffe auf Schiffe natürlich auch den
angraf Angriff auf das Schiff von
haperglud aufschärfste Aufnahmen der hui
Rebellen zeigen wie sie schon im
November die Galaxy Leader ein
Frachtschiff für Fahrzeuge karperern und
die Kontrolle über das Schiff übernehmen
auf Aufnahmen von Anfang Dezember ist zu
sehen wie das Frachtschiff vor der
jemenitischen Küste zu einer
propagandistischen Attraktion
umfunktioniert wurde besucher können auf
dem Deck über israelische und
amerikanische Flaggen laufen
touristenfotos machen auf den Verbleib
der Besatzung gibt es keine Hinweise
eine der vielbefahrensten Handelswege
der Welt 10 bis 15% des Welthandels
passieren die Route haakleut und die
dänische räderei mersk wollen sie nun
aber vorerst nicht befahren die
Alternative wäre eben ein Umweg über
7000 km der deutliche Verlängerung in
den Transportzeiten mit sich bringt die
Transportpreise nach oben treibt und
damit auch die Stabilität der
Lieferketten beeinträchtigt mehr
Militärpräsenz könnte die Route
zumindest sicherer machen die USA haben
Deutschland um Beteiligung am
Marineeinsatz gebeten der Antrag ist in
der
Prüfung und wir machen weiter mit
Gundula Gause und den Nachrichten und da
geht's um einen schwelenden
Tarifkonflikt Warnstreiks im
Einzelhandel kurz vor Weihnachten dazu
hat die Gewerkschaft werdi aufgerufen
indem seit rund 7 Monaten festgefahrenen
Tarifkonflikt Valerie Haller was ist aus
dem Handel zu hören wie sicher sind
damit die Weihnachtseinkäufe in den
Geschäften ja schon ziemlich sicher
Handelsexperten halten die Auswirkungen
der Warnstreiks für überschaubar das
gilt auch für den
Lebensmitteleinzelhandel der vermutlich
weniger betroffen sein wird als andere
Bereiche ähnlich sieht das der
Handelsverband HDE Einzelhändler hätten
schon in der Vergangenheit gezeigt dass
sie die Folgen möglichst gering halten
können heißt es wer aber auf Nummer
sicher möchte sollte dem Rat von
Handelsexperten folgen die Einkäufe
vorziehen und nicht erst kurz vor
Weihnachten shoppen gehen die ersten
Warnstreiks könnte es schon am
Donnerstag geben und warum ist dieser
Tarifkonflikt der Art
festgefahren ja gewerkschaft und
Arbeitgeber liegen einfach weit
auseinander werdi forder 2,50 € mehr pro
Stunde mit einer Laufzeit von einem Jahr
die Arbeitgeber bieten laut Gewerkschaft
für 2023 weniger als die Hälfte halten
ihr Angebot aber für historisch werdi
meint das reiche hinten und vorne nicht
mit ihrem Aufruf zu Warnstreiks
ausgerechnet in der umsatzstarken
Weihnachtszeit erhöht die Gewerkschaft
nun den Druck die Arbeitgeber aber
zeigen sich kämpferisch sie sagen sie
nehmen lieber Streiks in Kauf als einen
zu hohen Tarifabschluss der wäre in
ihren Augen fatal für die Branche vielen
Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt die AFD Vorsitzende Weidel
muss sich mit Plagiatsvorwürfen
auseinandersetzen die Universität bei
reut prüft laut Süddeutscher Zeitung
ihre Doktorarbeit von 2011 zwei
plagiatsucher hatten Weidel in einem
Gutachten das auch dem ZDF vorliegt
vorgeworfen fremde Quellen übernommen
und dies nicht ausreichen gekennzeichnet
zu haben Weidel weiß das als abwegig
zurück und eine Erfolgsmeldung von der
Biathlon Weltcup Premiere im
schweizerischen Lenzerheide Routinier
Benedikt doll aus reitnau landete auf
Platz 1 nach vor allem einer
eindrucksvollen Leistung am Schießstand
der letztjährige Überflieger Johannes
dbö aus Norwegen musste einmal in die
Strafrunde und holte Platz 2 vor dols
Teamkollege Philip navrad aus Nesselwang
im
Schwarzwald das war's von uns für heute
wir geben jetzt direkt ab an Matthias
forornoff und das ZDF
Politbarometer
[Musik]
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer eine Ampel sorgt
normalerweise dafür dass es geordnet und
verlässlich zugeht die politische Ampel
von rot grün und gelb steht eher fürs
Gegenteil der wochenlange
Haushaltsstreit ist zwar gelöst doch das
Vertrauen in die Regierung und auch in
den Kanzler ist nachhaltig erschüttert
so zeigt die Olaf Scholz
zufriedenheitskurve Stil nach unten zu
Beginn seiner Amtszeit vor knapp 2
Jahren bewährten 65% der befragten die
Arbeit des Bundeskanzlers als eher gut
kurz nach Ausbruch des ukrainekriegs ist
die Zufriedenheit mit ihm am größten
doch dann fällt die Kurve mehr oder
weniger kontinuierlich ab jetzt sind nur
noch 30% zufrieden mit seiner Arbeit 65%
finden dass Scholz seinen Job eher
schlecht
macht ein miserables zwischenzeug is zur
ampelhalbzeit stellen die Befragten aber
nicht nur dem Kanzler sondern der
gesamten Koalition aus nur etwa jeder
vierte findet diese Bundesregierung
macht ihre Sache eher gut
68% aber sind unzufrieden dass es eine
CDU CSU geführte Bundesregierung besser
könnte glauben allerdings nur 35% fast
die Hälfte würde keinen Unterschied
erwarten ein Alarmzeichen und wohl auch
Ausdruck eines allgemeinen
vertrauensverlusts in die etablierten
Parteien und ihre Vertreter bei unserer
Sonntagsfrage kann die Union kaum von
der Schwäche der Ampel profitieren wenn
jetzt Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD
auf 14% -1 ihr schwächster Wert seit
Regierungsantritt CDU CSU 32 +1 die
Grünen
14-1 FDP 5 AFD 20 die Linke vier alle
unverändert Freie Wähler
3%. SPD Grüne und FDP wären zusammen
etwa so stark wie die Union allein die
könnte ein Zweierbündnis anführen
entweder mit der SPD oder mit den
Grünen schauen wir auf unsere Top 10
also die Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung die negativ
bewertete Regierungsarbeit schlägt auch
hier durch Köpfe der Opposition Punkten
aber auch nicht wirklich auf der Skala
von +5 bis -5 ist aliesweidel
Schlusslicht
-2,2 deutlich besser vorletzte nennt sie
fäer wieder dabei
-1,3 Sarah Wagenknecht -1,1 verbessert
Olaf Scholz
-1,0 noch mal dramatisch abgerutscht
sein neuer Negativrekord Christian
Lindner
-0,5 auch Robert habbeck und Annalena
bererbock -0,5 beide verschlechtert
Friedrich März -0,1 besser Markus Söder
0,2 etwas verbessert mit Abstand vorn
weiterhin Boris Pistorius 1,7 etwas
schlechter Oppositionsführer Friedrich
März schaltet auf Attacke gegen die
Ampel scheint sich warm laufen zu wollen
als
Kanzlerkandidat doch mit wem hätte die
Union die besten Chancen bei der
nächsten
Bundestagswahl mit Markus Söder dem
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten sagen
28%. 20% halten Hendrik wüst den
Regierungschef von Nordrhein-Westfalen
für am besten geeignet auf cduchef
Friedrich märz als Kanzlerkandidat
setzen 16 auf Daniel Günther
Ministerpräsident von Schleswig-Holstein
10%. noch deutlicher fällt das Votum für
Söder bei den Anhängern der Union aus
März liegt hier knapp vor wüst Günther
auch hier
abgeschlagen seit fast zwei Jahren führt
Russland Krieg gegen die Ukraine die
Fronten scheinen festgefahren Putin
setzt auf Zeit und schwindende Hilfe für
Kiev 35% sagen der Westen sollte die
Ukraine militäis stärker unterstützen
als bisher deutlich mehr als Ende
November
die Unterstützung sollte so bleiben wie
sie ist mein 33% ein deutlicher Rückgang
weniger militärische Hilfe fordern
27%. zum Jahresende noch eine
persönliche Frage mit Blick zurück und
nach vorn wie war das Jahr
2023 und wie geht's weiter 66% sagen
dass dieses jah für Sie persönlich eher
gut war 31% schauen erer negativ drauf
und wie wird
2024 28% erwarten für sich persönlich
ein besseres Jahr
28% rechnen nicht mit Veränderung 13%
glauben es wird eher
schlechter bewahren wir uns so gut es
geht diesen
Optimismus das war unser Bericht über
die Stimmung im Land die Grafiken und
alle Informationen zu unseren Umfragen
finden Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab
Seite 165 in der zdfheute App und auf
zdfheute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de vielen Dank für
Ihr Interesse das nächste Politbarometer
gibt's dann am 12 Januar hier folgt
jetzt das Wetter danach geht's weiter
mit der heuthow einen schönen Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend so langsam können wir über
das Weihnachtswetter spekulieren aber es
bleibt bei Spekulationen geht es nämlich
nach dem amerikanischen Wettermodell
dann liegt in Dresden z.B an Heiligabend
7 cm Schnee bei einem grad das
europäische Wettermodell sieht das ganz
anders 8° und Regen also im Detail ist
noch alles möglich bei einer Sache sind
sind sich die Wettermodelle aber einig
Ende nächster Woche steht uns wohl ein
Sturm ins Haus da sind wir jetzt aber
noch nicht jetzt etabliert sich erstmals
seit langem wieder ein stabiles Hoch
über Mitteleuropa und das bringt uns ein
recht trockenes drittes
Adventswochenende und recht milde Luft
an seiner Nordseite deswegen sinken die
Temperaturen heute Nacht im Norden auch
nur auf 5 bis 3° im Süden ist es kühler
bei 3 bis -4°. etwas Schnee fällt noch
am erdzgebirge oder an den Alpen das
lässt aber nach im Norden gibt es viele
Wolken und der westliche Wind frischt
schon mal auf im Südwesten kann es
Aufklaren dann bildet sich allerdings
dicht der Nebel und der ist auch morgen
noch hartnäckig auf den Bergen im
Südwesten allerdings scheint Morgen die
Sonne im Norden gibt's aber viele Wolken
aus denen kann es auch mal nieseln dazu
wird der Wind noch lebhafter mit starken
böhnen an der Küste und er führt weiter
milde Luft heran 9° erreichen wir auf
den Ostfriesischen Inseln 3° im
Dauernebel und in höheren Lagen ja und
in den nächsten Tagen bleibt es weiter
mild aber mit diesem Unterschied
bewölkter windiger auch mal er Norden
windschwacher im Süden mit Sonne wenn da
nicht der Nebel dazwischen funkt
tschüss